if you're not afraid of what you're  giving away you're giving away too much  you're not giving away enough every time  I've written a book I always think to  myself oh God I'm sharing everything  they won't need me anymore it's the  opposite though a lot of things are the  opposite way you expect do you only get  trust from others by trusting first you  only get value back by giving value  first if you're afraid of giving away  all the secrets that you have I promise  you if you make content that does not  contain the secrets 99 of people will  just think you suck because you give  nothing because you're so afraid of  giving good stuff away